- You used a movement coach,
which I've also heard people use.
So, and they teach you to
be like certain animals.
I've actually heard this before as well,
and this must be a thing.
- It's a thing.
- Yes.
- I didn't go to drama school,
so I don't know if this is something
that everyone does in drama school,
but it's something I discovered after.
It's something I actually started doing
when I was on "I, Tonya."
So that was like the first time-
- What was your animal for "I, Tonya?"
- I was a pit bull.
- [Kelly] A pit bull.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That tracks.
- Because they're very
misunderstood, you know?
- Yeah. I like a pit bull.
- At first glance,
you're kind of like,
"Oh, should I be scared?"
I have a pit bull too,
so I love pit bulls.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But yeah, I wanted
like with her ice skates
and I wanted to be heavy on the feet.
I wanted her to feel like...
I wanted the character to
feel like the world was like
just bearing down on her all the time.
But then on the ice, she's
a mustang, like a wild horse
like on when she's ice skating,
so she's two animals really.
And then, yeah, every
character, I've had animals.
- [Kelly] Who is Nellie?
- Nellie?
- There's a lot of people in there.
- She's an octopus and a honey badger.
- Well, octopus, yeah, she's always...
- I bet no knew I was about to say that.
- I have honey badgers on my ranch.
Those are mean little-
- [Margot] Do you really?
- Yes, they are mean.
- They're insane.
- Yeah. Oh, I just...
You're the honey badger the scene
when you're eating all this
stuff with the rich people.
- Yes. That's honey badger.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- And then the snake fight scene,
that's all honey badger-like.
'Cause they're actual
videos of honey badgers
fighting snakes.
There's videos of honey badgers,
which aren't huge animals fighting like...
- [Kelly] But they're mighty.
- Lions and they have
like really thick skin
and they're just...
- [Kelly] That is just Nellie.
- They're just insane.
Like she's very thick skinned.
And she just fights anything and anyone
at the drop of a hat.
- And I love this trick.
- [Margot] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And it's helpful 'cause
you do all this research
and like, you know, there's
tons of research that,
you know, read all these books
and watch all these films
and get all these facts
about the real life people
at this time and what, you know,
and sometimes your head
gets so clouded with,
you know, statistics and
facts and the history,
and blah blah blah.
- Simplify just with movement, yeah.
- And if you just revert
back to the animal,
then you can just be
really, really instinctual.